how was it first of all to say goodbye
to Tyler into the show and he's been
such a big part of you for so many years
I think bittersweet is probably the best
way to describe it you know it's there's
like an exciting light at the end of the
tunnel to see what's next and to like
move on and do new things and now
knowing that I have all this time in
this experience under my belt and this
incredible new fan base of people that
are supporting me and my journey onwards
not only just fans who are incredible
but also like everyone that I've worked
with for four years now it's very
strange but we're all like talking in
the group chat that we have together and
just like texting each other and and
telling everyone how amazing they did
this season and we're trying to figure
out a time where we can all do like a
group FaceTime group zoom ya know saying
goodbye to Tyler yeah like it's it's set
I mean he's always gonna be a part of me
and I'm very proud of him in working
when and you know but but it is time you
know it's it's it feels like the right
time to move on
are you afraid yeah I do want to talk
about Tyler's journey but I also have to
ask you about something that sort of
surprised me but in hindsight did not
surprise me and that was okay Austin's
death yeah couldn't you read the script
what was your reaction
how did Brandon react like what the
cat's make of that yeah so fun story so
at the beginning of production I think
Brian had already told us like someone
is gonna die this season well you guys
too yeah he kind of he kind of usually
lets us know like we're gonna lose
someone but I'm not gonna tell any of
you especially because we films the
graduation like the outdoor graduation
stuff like within the first month of
production and then we didn't get to
that episode until the very end so he
told us someone was gonna be dying and
everyone every series regular was at the
graduation and he was like we're gonna
film all of you and then we're just
gonna take one of you out in editing
that way you guys never know and then so
all season long it was like who do you
guys think it's gonna be we kind of all
unanimously were like I think it would
be most
kind of impactful that was like Justin
or Toni her or something crazy yeah so
when we finally got down to the episodes
I don't really think anyone was too
surprised because I think we all kind of
know Brian's tricks now and in to some
degree I assume that Brandon knew oh you
did well I think Brian Brian likes to
tell us the information that we need not
the information we want and so I think
probably heading into those last episode
specifically Brandon probably really
needed that information but yeah I mean
I think it's the character of Justin
Foley is you know it's a tragedy and I
think it really impacted us all because
of how we feel about the characters and
how we want to see them move on but yeah
I mean I guess that that is the mark of
you know like a good character that we
all love if it grows on you so much and
it and it really impacts you when that
character it moves on and and is gone
with the show being a cautionary tale
it's more of like sort of the things
that we wish could happen to people but
also sometimes it's the unfortunate
truth of things that do happen and
especially dealing with something like
HIV and AIDS which is you know so
incredibly impactful to the LGBT
community and you know I think it's it's
still a thing that impacts people to
this day and it's it's not fun to think
about it's not enticing you know to want
to write a story about it but at the end
of the day it's like a character like
Justin Foley what he had to do to stay
alive on the streets what he himself
felt that he needed to do to survive and
how that impacted him it's tragic but it
also does happen to people they're my
friends
so anything you did to them you do to me
- um well your character after through
everything that Tyler went through got a
seemingly happy ending you did how how
did you feel about where he ended up I
feel really good about it I mean again
you know a cautionary tale in this show
you know we want to see people maybe go
through some some really horrible things
that people have to deal with today but
we think maybe what could happen for
these people to get them back on the
right track and to be able to move on in
a healthy manner where they can be
productive members of their communities
and have friendships and feel safe and
secure and and feel like they can
overcome these obstacles and be stronger
and come back better especially for
Tyler who's a character that I always I
always appreciated his is just a really
amazing trait that I've noticed where
he's always kind of the first one of
these characters to want to take
responsibility for the like the
wrongdoings that he's done that's what I
want people to be able to take away from
the character of Tyler that you can go
through these you know these pitfalls
and these ups and downs and and be hurt
and get back up and have people that are
supporting you and get professional help
and you can see your way forward and not
feel like you're stuck in one place and
that you can never move on from that I
will say speaking of being stuck in one
place I mean he came out the other side
of what I think and we've talked about
this scene before like one of the most
heartbreaking scenes of the entire
series do you think the finale did Tyler
justice a finale of a show is gonna be
super subjective to everyone I think
just seeing him having camaraderie with
friends with you know clay and Tony and
Charlie and Alex and everyone else and
and having them with that moment with
the tapes in the box at the end where
they all do get to say goodbye and he
had that amazing I really loved the
scene where he's with the college
interviewer and you know he really is
confronting his relationship with these
you know these weapons and talking about
why they enticed him and help ease me
Don and how they affect him now I think
that in the way that it shows his
progression his growth through that I it
is very satisfying to me at least being
able to see him come out that other side
in a way that he does feel more powerful
and himself and he feels more
comfortable and he feels more secure
especially with all these people and and
you kind of seem to get to come out of a
shell a little bit too with Estella and
he he actually has fun at prom we get to
see Tyler like dancing and having a good
time which isn't something that I ever
thought I'd see from him also I have to
I don't know if I'm married at all but I
had this yes thank Alex yeah I had this
made my god actually our our wardrobe
department I walked into costumes and I
asked them if they could help me make
this for our final table read and I
haven't worn it since because it would
be a spoiler but it is my favorite it's
probably my favorite relationship in the
entire season in the entire series
probably they're just so wholesome and
pure and charlie is such a good guy
they're so cute I love it
I honestly agree with you especially
Charlie being like a year young very
kind of more vulnerable and then him
being supported by the entire football
team you know I think it really is
showing this you know progression of you
know a release of toxic masculinity and
more people kind of understanding and
becoming more educated and more aware
about their friends around them it was
such a beautiful thing and that prom
dance the when they get crowned his
problem things oh my gosh I know I
freaked I'm pretty sure they probably
had to like edit my like they probably
turned my mic off because when they were
up top just like yeah I love that what
for you has been the reaction from fans
I feel like social media yeah social
media love this show so much and they
comment and they tweet so what what have
you seen
um just lots of support like I've seen a
lot of a lot of thank-you tweets that
have kind of like tagged all of us and
it's been like thank you so much for
this series
I saw one message yesterday from someone
who was asking for it season Hey
that's still in the same question do you
think there's room for more do you think
that there's room for oh I don't know I
don't know I like to think that this is
kind of the and like the close book on
the story of at least these characters
at Evergreen I feel like they've just
been through enough and they've worked
hard to come out the other end and the
way that they have and it would just I
think it would feel kind of cruel to
like make them go through something else
I don't know I know that Brian had had
initially an idea of like an anthology
series or something where we pick up
with like a new a new cast in a new
school with the new set of problems
which I think would be amazing and what
about for you is there like a dream role
are you alright do you have anything
like what's the future look like for you
I want to be in a Marvel movie more than
anything in the world
wait yes are you I don't know what role
in the Marvel Universe are you ieaving
would you want to play I love the
character of Richard Rider he is a is a
spirit called Nova in the guardians of
the galaxy movie we see a little bit of
the the Nova Corps with john c reilly
who is ya know incredible i love him
this character was initially created he
was meant to kind of be like a Peter
Parker in like the 70s though so I think
that would be a lot of fun my first like
favorite movie my first experience in a
movie theater that I can remember is
seeing Sam Raimi's spider-man in 2002
there's room for me to get in there I
would look at you know if they're
casting for that character I have no
idea really no idea I just know that
it's been like a fin I I would love to I
know that fans of kind of he's a fan
favorite if anyone ever needs any help
anytime anyplace just send a group text
say Gordon Lightfoot do you have a
message to the fans I mean yes but I'm
also like what do I even say cuz I feel
like there's not enough words or that
there are words that are accurate
I hope that they take away these great
messages of you know finding a strength
to move on and supporting each other
especially right now you know like not
to get too preachy or anything but with
these black lives matter movements like
the black lives matter and it's super
important to get this word out right now
and I love in our episode eight these
kids are able to overcome this
overstepping of you know enforcement in
their school is that we have all these
kids joining forces together and
everyone is brought to the attention to
let these incredible black women you
know stand up and leave them and have
you know this you know peaceful moment
and and standing up together and through
that they're able to overcome this thing
and I think that that's always something
I'm gonna remember yeah you can keep
with me and I'm just so proud
[Music]